Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Hack, now this indie game on GameJolt- Hi. You think that I need training?
Excuse me. Do you know who I am?
My vision center? Are you talking about my eyeballs?
Why should I do that? Why thought I thought that being the vulnerable was, b- oh. Did I just karate chop that?!
What!?
Oh, okay. Alright then. Is this some kind of Portal companion cube bullshit? Oh I can lifty-loo with the right button.
Okay
Okay, so I can't hack through that one but I can-okay. Karate chop that bad boy into POW-town. Oh, get here, alright.
Well, I did it hey!
Hey, Look at me, look at me!
Oh looky looky at me can I I?
I seem to be at the end of the- Oh got a karate chop this BAM baby.
You beat this level, could be better though. I got so many points! If that was dollars, I'd be so happy!
Three hacks? Okay. Well I'll go to the
Next level in I have no idea what's happening, but I feel pretty confident in my abilities to hack st- oh...
Well hi hello, I can't... can't walk through that... Can I hack it?
Pachow with my magic fingers around my green circle around my eyeball boobie... aah BONKIE.
Woah, I'm data!
Whoa, I don't know how...
What the hell?
I love... (giggles) it. I love it. I already love it. Oh that's nice. Get there?
I don't know if I want to do that yet. I got to find out what's going on here in this portal world
It's a mystery. It can't be solved! BAM. all right hippity hop. Oh, that's cool. Hackity Hackie!
Hey can you come back down? I wasn't ready for that. Can you come back d-aww
I gotta hack it again. This all right fine dooby doobady turn that offity wobbity. Get crushed. Can I get crushed to death?
AAAH
Oh, I'm fine
I guess everything turned out better than expected alright swoopdy whoopdy swibbity wibbity. Alright, at least it remembers where I was looking before.
That's awfully handy dandy wandy of that.
Blap.
I Don't know what I'm doing with that, but it's amazing. Whatever my green laser finger gun is, I want one in real life.
Thank you. It is like portal!
Ahaha Hey!
It could be better though that's what I tell myself every morning. I always could be better you know
I'm never quite as good as I want to be.
Hello, do I have to walk hey?
How's it going there? Jump! Oh? There's an orange? Oh? There's an orange? Okay? Well I gotta find something.
So I'm alright. Hey come back here! Oh, oh it's an invisible rope.
Hey, come back here. Don't make me sass you cuz I will oh yeah.
You...
Never mind I couldn't come- oh no!
No, you goofed me. Oh frick. Now I got infinitely more time to come up with an insult for you!
*silence*
You purp...
*more silence*
Alright, we'll let bygones be bygones just oh, ho you went a whoopty on that one. I'll find out okay
I got I got I know it I got a bu-do come here for you pick you up. No! Don't goof me! Aah!
I could have jumped from the other platform. Well you piece of shit.
Now you really done did it because now, oh, I'm not gonna let up on the insults whoa. This is real?
I Don't like that. I don't like that at all. alright, don't goof me. Don't goof me. I can't look down
I can't look down right now. Oh, I'm on it. Okay. This is real. Apparently, it's real I mean
I thought it was real the
Simulation before was what looked like not real. Can you just settle on the button you piece of garboo
Hi-ya! Ya?
What did that do?
Oh. Oh. Oh. Ah.
Frick a dick oh, but I know how to do this don't goof me! No!
Yes
Okay, almost goofed myself there ye. ah doosky. Alright, You plop on that bad boy right there, and we're going
We're golden
So if this is if this is real then what's the point of it, right?
They're saying something about in the beginning of that
It was some computer program telling me that I was doing security on something and things are vulnerable, but it's not the real world... so...
Seboushski
Ooh... fancy shmancy
Well that's one... we're gonna go on an adventure aren't we? alright. Wow we're going places good thing they
blue buddy blue, buddy, Oh
What does that do?
What does that do ah
Oh
Frick a dick oh, I'm way off
OH duh, Oh duh, i just pff ah duh
Just gotta freaking go back and then go through well
I'm dumb that took me that took me longer than the editing would suggest it took me
Haha, but we're gonna all pretend like  I'm a super smart. Whoa this camera is Wibbly oh
No why oh? Why is this the way-  ah
Titty sprinkles I was here, but I can't hack any whoa oh
OOOOH i can hack
Oh, I did not know that okay. Well I should go there?
Back up a little bit
Man these puzzles are a thing
Ooh! Hey! Ho!
Hey-ho hey-ho come here hey, ho get over here, sorry, that's very rude of me, but get on that button ah
we did it if this isn't the real world that I'm a
Monkey's uncle. I did terribly on that one. I did god-awful, but let's keep going because I don't want to end on that note
Whoa?
Does that mean risk of catastrophic failure or is that a cannon that's gonna blow up that other cannon?
I have no idea. Is that a turret battle seems like it might be a turret battle. Ooh. Box! Can I get you?
Got ya I broke the system, I don't know if I actually broke the system oh
Hey, scare-wee
Stop just get on there and let me jump on you. Whoa didn't expect that to actually work. Hey broke the system. Love it. Oh
Ah, shit alright whatever fine, we'll be like that.
AH!
I know what it wanted
That was a mistake
Okay, you're gonna move
Ah
oh
They're not powered right now
Iteres- whoa. what the frickie dick? Well alright. Well. Why are you so bad?
Alright, whatever just gonna get out of here. See ya see ya now
I'm gonna get up on this again get up on this now. I'm gonna go over here cuz I'm cheating oh
Hey, that looks like it'll kill me. Let's test that theory oh. Oh it's not if you dodge it
No
Frick. Titty sprinkles all right fine you want to be that way and you're gonna be that way all right
So I'm gonna put you right there, and I'm not gonna touch ya. AH! I shoulda touched ya!
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba, why is this not working?
That's unfortunate alright fine. I'm gonna take my prize and be on my way.
Excuse me alright, so there's got to be a way to start up the power right.
Immediately ow. Ah! Come back!
You asshole
fucking douche! come baaaack!
Come back
Oh, you're not coming back, are you?
You're not coming back. Well. I guess I'll die then. Ow, I died.
Frick my donker. Don't like that
Alright, we're moving gonna snag you a snagged. good snagged real good, okay, alright, so
I got ya
bla-bla-bla-bla-blow How are you? Are you not exploding? I'm trying to this should work, right ah
Oh gotta aim for the base. Oh, Oh your base are belong to boom well. You're dead now
I grab this and I'll just be on my way scuse me. I don't fubble knuck me.
I said don't fubble knuck me
This is a tight squeeze
Alright you know what I don't like that and you don't like me and we don't like each other. Where did I go okay?
Whatever, you know what we're gonna go with that is the thing that happening? Oh?
shitty dicks no no no oh
OH NOOOO!
Fuck you! Fuck you in a million ways. In a million days! fuck you. Since I think it's gonna be fine
I'm gonna leave this there now and then drop off welp apparently I'm not. Apparently I'm gonna go upside-down err
If I just time this welp didn't time that no get back in your spot you oh
It worked I was about to complain, but then it worked ok yes, yes
Ok so anyway that is all the time I got for this one. This is cool though. I like it
It's pretty darn cool
They got some good mechanics going on here
And I can really appreciate that there's also some
Competitiveness to it because there's speedruns so if you want to play this game for yourself
It's a unique puzzle, and it's got some cool elements to it. I'll put a link in the description below
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh Bye!
*outro music*